yes I'm totally gonna get up early  tomorrow and work out  is the alone definitely on I should  check are they all on I should check  just let's check one more time how is it  morning already  I swear I literally just went to sleep  hit snooze one more time one more other  time  so noses got I'll just figure out what's  wearing my head what clothes do we own  why can't I think of anything that I own  what's on it work today  good they call me sick [ __ ] I have a  presentation I'm a horrible person I am  the worst why do I do this every single  day I have to get up right now  if I want to make it to work on time oh  I really want to check Instagram and  Facebook and time off that's  time-sensitive  okay you can do this just 911 told them  being bet again six more hours then I  can be in bed again  can I left with my car at lunch uh okay  one more episode I won't be that tired  in the morning